decided to go to the golf course for
dinner
and they've recently planted this nice
little hedge which is just a delightful
meal for the deer bunch of deer here and
it's been wet here not seriously could
you came he whatever it is enjoying yeah
pretty good stuff this is the 10th hole
here and
and there are some people out deep you
know friends the deer is the golf course
where my wife likes to play all the time
I'm filming this from the deck I played
hockey this morning and came here to
have lunch to use up our quarterly you
know allowance er money that we have to
spend in the restaurant but basically
you can see the first hole here the
cutting area the little practice area
for your short game and the background
there's the second hole green then there
is the ninth hole over there green and
over here we have the 18th hole and over
the other side of it is the 10th hole
and when the weather is nice it's really
very nice except to me Golf is time away
from language learning or other more
interesting pursuits but I do it
nevertheless because it's something I
can do together with my wife hi there
there was a brief look at our Golf
Course which is a 2025 minutes from here
I wanted to show you that because the
theme today is you know and I had an
opportunity to go and play golf with my
wife but I chose not to
that's number of reasons first of all I
got to walk the dog but I could have I
have on occasion called and said I'm not
walking the dog it's because I feel I
want to get going on my Korean and I
think one of the things that people
often say well how do you learn
languages well one of the first things
is you have to sometimes sacrifice other
activities people always say I don't
have time I don't believe that people
don't work 24 hours a day you find the
time if that is a priority for you so we
can find the time we just decide to do a
instead of be a being learn languages
now it helps if you can learn in a way
that's enjoyable so I say I won't play
golf but I'm gonna be listening to my
podcast which I enjoyed
and I'm gonna be doing it while walking
in the forest which I enjoy doing so
it's an activity I'm not gonna be
sitting there looking at conjugation
tables trying to pound them into my head
I'm gonna be listening to this podcast
and if I have enough time I will read in
order to try and go over this text and
understand more of it and save words and
so forth so it's a choice between
something that is not ah I wouldn't say
equally enjoyable but but the language
is something that I want to do so so the
key thing is to make that commitment and
spend the time as I've said many times
before and another thought that I had
was you know I was thinking you know I'd
like to go to Korea to practice my
Korean because I know that week or two
there will give me a big boost and of
course I did that with Russia and I
studied Russian for five years and then
I went to st. Petersburg and Moscow
spoke Russian and had a great time and
it helped my Russian check I I spent a
good year and a half then I went to
Prague and for six or seven days I maybe
was a year I spent that first time and
then for six or seven days I did nothing
but speak Czech and I significantly
activated a lot of my passive vocabulary
now the trouble with going to Korea too
early is that I'm still in the in the
process of accumulating my vocabulary of
doing that listening and reading to make
my brain familiar with the language if I
go there and and like when I went to
Prague I arranged with I had two tutors
on the go out we had meetups with link
members we I arranged to meet with
different people so that I was speaking
Czech six or seven hours a day now if I
don't have enough vocabulary I don't
want to spend six or seven hours a day
going round and round in circles saying
the same stuff about you know how long
I've been studying Korea and whatever I
can say comfortably I want to be able to
go over there and then have meaningful
conversations on a variety of subjects
and then activate my passive vocabulary
so I don't want to go there too early
again it's a question of yeah spend the
time but spend the time wisely spend the
time
joyeux bleah spend the time in a way
that gives you a good return
so the theme today is main thing about
language learning spend the time but
spend it wisely
that's my yeah why can't I should
mention by the way once you have
achieved some ability in the language
then there's so many benefits like I'm
gonna do a video later on this evening
about the situation in Ukraine and so I
have I listened to a couple of
interviews a Tekamah squeee one of the
more liberal bent and one of the more
pro-government bent I discovered that
the candidate for presidency in Ukraine
nominated by the Party of Regions is
interviewed on the Shuster live program
because I wouldn't have a look there
what is he got he's got a I see pictures
of dobkin who is the head of day that
you know the candidate for the party
reasons so I can listen to them and they
I presume were gonna speak in Russia so
I get to enjoy all this stuff with my
language I when they had the political
crisis in in the Czech Republic I was
able to follow the events which led to
the they you know the dismissal of the
government then they you know the
elections were called and have their new
president and stuff like that
controversial figure too so those are
the benefits one day I will be at that
level in Korea I'm not there yet so
that's all for now and those of you who
are interested in discussing politics I
can listen to me later if I in fact find
the time to do that thanks for listening
bye